hello how are you I am at 3 gonzález with your
brief informative for today Friday
March 19 the moratorium on evictions has
helped people to stay in
their homes in recent months due
to the crisis caused by the pandemic
however this will end the first
April 1, city leaders held
a virtual meeting the night where they
said that if you receive an
eviction notice regarding the hobbit you
should respond immediately online or in
person at court if you do not show
up this eviction may be made
automatic  well also get help
through the program that you are housing
for a more detailed list of
resources available visit houston
out dot com diagonal in spanish many
people will be eligible to receive the
vaccine against food
starting next week those
older residents  16-year-olds with
pre-existing medical conditions can start
vaccinating on Monday, April 5
every  over 16 years old will be able to receive
this anywhere for now
only people with
pre-existing health conditions can make an appointment at
a pharmacy like smith or walk
the clark county school district
is gradually receiving more
students in their classrooms students  from
pre-kindergarten to third grade are already
studying a
hybrid learning model on Monday grades
6, 9 and 12 will begin with this model for
more information about this school plan
visit our page at news now
dotcom diagonal in Spanish and now
we will see the  weather forecast
we will have pleasant temperatures in
southern nevada reaching 80 degrees
spring is coming tomorrow with some
winds in the valley and temperatures
around 70 degrees have a
nice day I am from andrés gonzález and
this was about the news bulletin from him  news
now in Spanish
[Music]